On Monday, I did the pull up routine that Daniel always does.
So sore today. Like,
my back, my chest.
Like, all these muscles right here.
So sore. I went running today.
Just the running motions. I was in pain.
So I'm trying to get a lot of protein in
so all that work doesn't go to waste.
Two cups.
So two cups of sheep's milk,
vanilla bean. See the black vanilla specs in there?
I'm gonna put that in,
and it's so good.
Out the vanilla bean, we have a creamy chocolate,
and then we have the maple cinnamon.
These are the three flavors that are coming again next month.
They're so good. Ingredients are incredible.
Colostrum grass, bedweet collagen,
hemp protein. They have sea salt.
This one has the maple sugar in it.
Late season maple. And the cinnamon is made from cocoa powder.
No artificial flavors, you guys.
It's all the wrong. So yummy.
Mmm.